in just four days California will become
the latest state to allow sales of
recreational marijuana pot sales will be
legal in eight states and the District
of Columbia in 2018 but California
businesses will face a complicated
rollout in order to sell it Carter Evans
is at a medical marijuana dispensary in
Los Angeles Carter good morning good
morning we're at a shop called urban
trees and right now they only sell
medical marijuana but they would like to
get a license to sell recreational to do
that though things are going to have to
change for example this brownie here has
500 milligrams of THC the new limit is
only 100 milligrams and then it has to
be divided into ten milligram doses and
that's just the beginning
come January first anyone 21 years of
age or older will be able to buy
recreational marijuana legally in
California that is if they can find a
place allowed to sell it some local
governments are banning pot shops
altogether while others are still
working through the permitting process
Kat Packer is the head of Los Angeles's
cannabis regulation department this is a
process not an event
la won't even begin accepting license
applications until January third and it
could take weeks before stores are
properly licensed to sell recreational
marijuana we do not want to necessarily
disrupt this market but we do need to
regulate this market medical shops like
Torrey holistic sin San Diego faced
challenges in becoming recreational
sellers so you've had to create new
packaging we did our packaging is
completely changing so that it is not
see-through opaque childproof packaging
is just part of the new rules here this
is 115 pages what is this this is the
proposed regulations by the state of
California so these are the rules you
gotta follow these are the rules we're
following so it's a really really nice
recreational pot users will have plenty
of rules to smoking marijuana is not
allowed in restaurants bars and most
public areas also off-limits your car
and the California Highway Patrol wants
everyone to know about the dangers of
driving while high did
that's smoking a joint can get you a DUI
if you can buy a drink or buy a joint
you can also afford a lift an uber a
taxi to avoid the tragedy that can
follow for California the stakes are
also high with the population here
approaching 40 million people this could
become a 7 billion dollar industry flat
alright Carter Evans for us with the
wonderful marijuana puns Thank You
Carter